[Music]
thank you for inviting me lovely to be
here my name is Nigel I'm going to talk
to you a bit about neo4j and how we can
work with that from Python it's nice to
be really just after lunch spot so I'll
try to be extra specially interesting so
that nobody falls asleep right let's
talk a bit about Who I am and what nee
FJ is so my name's Nigel small I'm the
driver technology lead at neo technology
I'm behind the bolt binary protocol that
we introduced without 3.0 version last
year and the the official drivers that
we launched prior to that we just had
community drivers for our HTTP interface
but we've now developed official drivers
for Python and some other languages that
you're probably not very interested in
I've been involved I've been at the
company for two and a half years but
I've been involved in the community
since the middle of 2011 you know very
Python overlaps with neo4j kind of
capacity I'm a multi language programmer
historically but most at home in Python
anyway so if I like a good place to come
and be amongst friends neo4j is a graph
database management system so we are
used to storing data in tables we store
data and graphs instead near technology
itself is based all over the world
its main engineering offices in Sweden
although we have a London office in an
office in California as well started
life as an embedded Java I once see the
Java web sorry the J library and it's
now a full fully blown database product
with everything you'd expect from a
database cypher is our query language
showing where you'd normally be using
sequel when you're working at the tables
we've got cypher instead and I'll go
into a little detail about that later on
but the whole thing is open source on
github so there's a lot you can look
into that if you want to play around you
can go to a download page we've got
distributions in a number of different
formats
good point thank you we've got
distributions in a number of different
formats so we've got our tables as well
as Debian packages Windows packages and
everything else as well very easy to get
up and running and we have a browser
component which lets you run queries and
visualize the results nicely which which
lets you explore a data model so the Neo
take on a graph what does it look like
well we have our nodes which are the the
vertices we call the nodes and they
represent the objects in your in your
domain that you're trying to model so
here we're modeling a couple of people
sort of person nodes and a car and the
relationships between those are defined
as the the connections that have a
direction have a type and may also have
some form of some set of properties on
them the properties on the know it's a
really where you're storing the data
that you're interested in playing with
so so for a person node you may have a
name a date a date of birth a twitter
handle and so on and and the the name
value pairs that we have things that
must have here to the to the Swiper type
system which we can look at a bit later
as well
so cipher is a declarative language it's
based on sequel so if you've used sequel
which obviously most of you have it'll
be very very familiar but it's it's real
selling point is that it it has a
capacity to match patterns in graphs in
in a very visual way we use an ASCII art
syntax for that and it'll look a bit
like this so if we want to match a
couple of nodes together with a with a
relationship in between them we'd create
a match clause the nodes would be
represented as as items within the the
round brackets and we draw an arrow
between them with a with a square
bracket identifier for the relationship
type within the round brackets then
we're looking at nodes that are with a
labeled person and a node can have one
or more labels attached to it they're
like tags then sort of Akins
table names I suppose in some ways
but but but more so where you can have
multiple ones somebody could be a person
and an employee and female have you
wanted to put in there the relationship
type then there's exactly one of those
so in this case we're matching a loves
type and then the properties themselves
can be included within the within the
note notation if you're if you're doing
in the exact match overall to run a
query your piece together a number of
clauses so there'll be one or more match
match clauses typically where you can
match one of these ASCII art patterns
you can filter those with with a where
clause where sub-clause you can have
some optional matches which are kind of
equivalent to a very of a left join us
suppose in table world then there's a
width and return Clause that you'll be
interested in the return is the
equivalent of your select but it goes at
the end and it will select things out of
the the patterns that you've matched and
allow you to return them and width
allows you to change
several sets of matches together if
you're doing several layers of
aggregation for example you may want to
use that and then all the by skip and
limit should be familiar for anyone
familiar with sequel so from Python how
do you then use this well we've got our
official driver the neo4j
- driver package on the Python package
index once you've got that installed you
can import the graph database object and
that allows you to create a driver which
which you can connect to a database
running on a particular machine with
some authentication details very
straightforward and then you create a
session and your session is a context
for running several transactional pieces
of work session run will let you run a
very simple auto commit transaction and
here we're just we're just generating
two values we're not actually touching
the graph in this particular example but
we're returning an integer a boolean and
a float and calling them a B and C and
then out of run you get a result object
and the data method on that is one
that'll be really interesting for anyone
who wants to integrate with something
such as pandas where you can just
collect up your entire result
and return it as a as a list of maps you
typically want to parameterize Seifer
when you're using it so where you can if
you want to write a statement like the
one at the top where you're matching on
an exact exact name and it's exact
string there typically I want to use
that in a in with it with the
substitution parameter and in that spot
instead and pass in a set of parameters
to substitute and the reason for this is
that the cipher engine that receives it
will be able to optimize if it sees sees
the same statement coming in more than
once the same exact string so you may be
searching for Alice you may be searching
for Bob and somebody else later on the
cipher engine will only have to compile
that once when it sees the exact match
for the string it will retrieve the
compiled version you know generally get
better performance overall results out
of the other side is a result is a
stream of records each record is as
you'd expect for a record it's it's
ordered and it's a keyed set of values
and then the values themselves adhere to
the cipher type system which looks a bit
like this so you can have null values
and interestingly we we don't have a we
don't have a specific difference between
what is a null value of what's actually
missing from your from your set of key
value pairs so if you're missing a
property within it within a node say if
somebody doesn't have a date of birth
attached then you'll get a null back
null and missing I've treated
identically they map to none obviously
in Python billions integers floats do
everything that you expect them to do
strings map to strings or unicode if
you're if you're still running Python to
lists lists of map the lists Maps map to
dictionaries and then we have a few
graph structures specific types you can
actually return entire nodes
relationships or a full path which is a
history of a walk through a graph you
can return those backing queries as well
and typically you might be interested in
doing that if you're building some form
of visualization all you want to get a
whole set of data and want to later do
some
things with it drilling into the data
within that so I'm going to try to demo
a little bit we've got a data set that
we've taken out of Yelp if you're not
familiar with Yelp it's a business
review site where you can review bars
restaurants and so on various cities
around the world and they have a
periodically they they they drop a set
of data onto the website there's made
available for for a data set challenge
we've picked up those they come in CSV
format we've translated them into a
graph and it looks a little bit like
this on the meta level so we have users
users can be friends with other users
they can write reviews reviews are about
a particular business and businesses
fall into particular categories so I'm
gonna switch over to try to show you how
this might look there we go so here's
some code this first bit of code before
we can't see that let me blow that up a
little bit more try to fill the screen a
little better you know where you see
that yep cool so what we're trying to do
here is simply connect to the database
and begin a session to carry out some
work so I'm pulling in the graph
database object from the near-future
driver I'm pulling in a panda's data
frame and I'm creating a driver instance
so here we see we're connecting using
the bulb protocol to a database I've got
running on a local host the default port
is 76 87 and the authentication details
are there so we've got a very secure
password there obviously it's writing a
local host that we find we then create a
session so this is our container for our
work so if I run that we get nothing out
of it it's nothing interesting to see at
this point but we can start looking at
how we might do some run some ciphers so
we want to match some nodes and here
where we're basically matching a
selection of 10 businesses in Edinburgh
that have at least 100 reviews on them
so we've got a match
clause here we're matching business
knows we're filtering by City and we're
filtering on having a review count to at
least 100 and then we're just returning
a set of properties that were interested
in so the name the city the review
counter the number of stars and limiting
to the first ten of those so we can see
we get out a nice table and I've wrapped
this into a data frame to output because
it gives a nice tabular couple of view
the the data method there again as I
mentioned earlier will let us take this
entire result and do that very simply so
we're seeing what we'd expect to see a
set of a set of businesses and the
things that we've asked for we can
similarly match some relationships so
here we're seeing we're matching reviews
that are that are on business again in
Edinburgh and we're looking for the
funniest reviews and listing the top ten
of those so we'll see the match pattern
here it's a little different it's it's
matching two nodes with a reviews link
in between them or again filtering by
city here and we're returning the text
the funny in this level and we're
ordering by the most funny and again
we're limiting to ten so we can see
there straight forward table coming out
of that aggregation so in in cipher
group by is implicit so everything
you're not putting an aggregation
function on will be grouped so here
we're looking at the total number of
reviews and the average star count for a
selection of ten businesses it's kind of
just a random selection in this case and
we're so we're doing a match on all
businesses we are then taking taking
those businesses and doing some
aggregation work on them so we're doing
a sum on the review count taking an
average of the number of stars
and we're grouping by city as I say
there's no explicit need for a group by
clause there because it works it out for
you we're then filtering those
aggregated results this is the equipment
of a having in some ways and then we're
we're returning those values at the
bottom so that should give us exactly
what we expect at the bottom now the API
itself has more capability than just
being able to run simple queries we've
introduced recently what's called what
are called transaction functions so
these allow you to wrap up a unit of
work into a into a function object and
use the session dot read transaction
method which is this one here and
similarly there's a there's a write
transaction method and that allows you
to to take that unit work pass it in it
makes the code more reusable you've got
you've got you've got your unit work
that you can use in various places
within your code it creates a nice
separation between your your application
logic in your and your database logic
but it also enables unlocks and a retry
capability that we've we've built in so
if you're using a cluster behind the
scenes we can replay that unit of work
on on we can play it first of all on one
cluster member if that fails if we get a
connection error or some form of
transient error then that will be
automatically replayed on one of the
other one of the other cluster members
so you can take away some of the the
worried about running things having to
having to manage that yourself that it
so here I've got a couple of transaction
functions the first one is very
straightforward count of the number of
number of user nodes that I have in my
database out of the the run method again
we get a result as we'd expect and
there's a single method that you can run
on that on that result that'll take the
take the first record out of the result
and generate a warning if there's
anything more there's return typically
your users where you expect there to be
only one only one row return and if
anything else happens then it's a bit of
a problem
and from that record we're simply
extracting the first value that we get
back this is a straight forward count
query and then the second transaction
function here does more less the same
thing but will would do if I didn't
change it by laughing it does the same
thing but it does a filter on name first
and we're passing that name into the
transaction function you can see here
when we call it we can just pass a set
of arguments and the arguments and
keyword arguments you pass into this
method are passed into the into the
transaction function itself so if I run
this I'm counting the number of users in
my database and also counting how many
of those are called Nigel this is very
popular name as you can see so we've got
a million users 53 of them for Nigel
I've only ever once worked with another
Nigel and he was the imposter definitely
so if I jump back to the slides here
some some more fancy patterns that we
might want to Explorer and these are for
friends our friends so this is something
that the cipher is very good at it's
very expressive and something you might
not better do so easily in it in in the
world of tables so the first example
there will simply look for anyone who
has a friend called Dave there's a
signal simple relationship from one user
to another with a similar single single
hop of a friend's relationship the
second example then does two steps so
it's looking for someone who's who's got
a friend of a friend called Dave
regardless of whether you have a friend
called Dave as well you might have you
might know someone who does generally
everybody has a Frankl Dave in my
experience but that's because I'm in
Britain it's probably less common name
last where the third example is a
rewrite of the second example this does
exactly the same thing and it collapses
those two friends relationships into
into a single relationship
there's times too so we're looking for
two hot friends relationships and all of
this is reasonably straightforward so
you probably be able to do this with a
couple of joins in most table in most
table based databases but the one thing
that then becomes easier if you want to
match variable length relationships so
the fourth example shows you how to
match anything between 1 & 2 so if you
know someone called Dave depth 1 or 2 or
going further obviously you can you can
solve things like the Kevin Bacon
problem where you can see how far away
you are from a particular this one here
yes the V to the two round brackets the
two parenthesis you mean yes basically
that that draws an empty node in the
middle so you're always going to be
hopping between a node yeah
relationships I can only join notes they
can't join other relationships so we're
just drawing an empty spot in the middle
but the third form there that you see
collapses that so you don't even have to
worry about the the bits that you put in
brackets can actually hold a number of
things so they can hold an identifier
for that node here we'll see a and B or
identifies and there identifies that are
only relevant in within that query they
held no permanent meaning within the
database the labels are the things that
follow the colon so you might have :
user : employee : something else and
then obviously the curly brackets can
contain the properties in there but if
you have none of those you're not
interested in those then empty brackets
are perfectly saying syntax as well so
in the browser just to illustrate that
quickly you can see I've run a couple of
these so actually if I scroll down
through the first one first
I'm only limiting here because I've got
million users in the database JavaScript
kind of scream at me if I try to run all
of these in the browser so I've limited
five here you can see I'm running the
the match here for user to user with two
hops again filtering by those who know
someone who know someone called Dave
and the start here you'll see this P
equals which is where we're we're taking
the entire path that we've matched and
returning that so the return P will
return the entire path object so that's
the that's the nodes and the
relationships and everything that makes
that up and then in this in this
representation you can see there's a few
people there who who know a Dave at
length too and the people in between
them and similarly here I'm doing the
same thing for anyone who knows a Dave
or knows who knows about it makes no
sense and you can see here we've got a
similar set of similar set of data so
very useful for those for those kind of
things you wouldn't necessarily be able
to do so easily in a table so if you've
tried this and you're getting stuck with
anything there's lots of places you can
find help we've got a cypher ref card
online and this gives you some snippets
for how to use each of the each of the
cypher clauses are available well you
can do more than just reads how many
I've only mentioned reads here today but
there are a whole set of clauses for
doing creation and deletion and merging
and so on and so on there's a lot more
richness to it than I've mentioned so
hop along there and you can see a very
easily digestible page we have some
language guides for working with the
drivers so Python and the rest of them
are all on there and there are there's
the official driver there are obviously
a load of community efforts around that
as well so you'll see a lot of a lot of
interesting Python and we have some
mailing lists that you might be
interested in joining a slack channel
which is which is now got a huge number
of people in it and so your you'll
easily find somebody who will answer
your question if you're stuck with
something and there's a group email
address you can you can drop celina if
you want to as well and i'm on twitter
i'm technology so if you want to find me
there and that's it thank you very much
[Applause]